she picked him up leaned on assured
adamite art sell a facade or some
present ella prepared a film that well
raise it as unique I know this because
I'm married to a man who makes foreign
language films at least in the United
States their foreign language films in
France funny girl is a foreign language
film oh yeah
also in Egypt look
another way foreign language films are
shown in the United States is with dub
dialogue sometimes the voices use do not
fit the actors faces when this happens
my husband gets very upset the
nominations for best foreign language
films are the boys of Paul Street
Hungary fireman's ball Czechoslovakia
the girl with the pistol Italy stolen
kisses France Warren peace Russia and
the winner is Russia for Warren peace
star of Warren peace with Milla
savelyeva
loosen yourself the Ava's Casa Natasha
Renee is my link I became a - yeah
oh but don't cut any hair no okay mother
I'm sorry I I asked at me love what her
friends call her and she said Lucy and
she asked me what my friends call me and
I said Natasha and then Lucy said that's
the name of her daughter and I said she
looks so young to be a mother
hmm we never ever Ojinaga Yoshi she a
sliver if I to public daddy's at
swimming at the minute my warriors is
yours yes your coochie I sneaked at
Mashable humor the priest 9 - you are
grown with Ruth back thank you very much
I love you